te has preguntado qué es lo que pasa
cuando nosotros tenemos el
comportamiento final de una función que
es un polinomio bueno justo eso es lo
que quiero ver en este vídeo quiero
analizar el comportamiento final de un
polinomio y vamos a ponerlo aquí el
comportamiento con x
está viento un final final y bueno me
estoy refiriendo al final pero también
me voy a fijar en qué es lo que pasa al
inicio comportamiento final me refiero a
qué es lo que pasa cuando x se vuelve
muy muy muy pero muy negativa o muy pero
muy pero muy positiva es decir qué es lo
que pasa los extremos y bueno sé que por
ahorita no me estás entendiendo nada
pero qué te parece si empezamos a ver
cómo se comporta la gráfica de una
función cuadrática así que empecemos a
ver una función a que igual y vamos a
hablar de una parábola de la parábola
que ya conocemos y igual
a equis cuadrada más bx más c perfecto
ahora está te cuentan que esto es una
función cuadrática esto es una parábola
y además nosotros conocemos bastante
bien a las parábolas así que si yo te
digo que a es más grande que cero a es
más grande que cero
este valor de aquí entonces tenemos una
parábola que abre hacia arriba y por lo
tanto vamos a dibujarlo por aquí tengo
una parábola más o menos así que abre
hacia arriba de lujo ok ahora si yo te
pregunto qué es lo que pasa cuando a es
menor que cero cuando es menor que cero
entonces me vas a decir que tenemos una
parábola que abre hacia abajo así que
vamos a ponerlo por aquí tengo una
parábola una parábola una parábola más o
menos así que abre hacia abajo ok de luz
ahora lo que me quiero preguntar con el
comportamiento final de esta función
cuadrática aquí es que es lo que va a
pasar cuando x es muy pero muy pero muy
negativa date cuenta que entonces el
valor de james el valor de esa expresión
se hace positivo y cuando x es muy pero
muy pero muy positiva pasa que también
el comportamiento de james el
comportamiento de esta expresión se
vuelve positivo y cuando es menor que
será un pase lo contrario cuando x es
muy pero muy pero muy negativa el
comportamiento de james
un valor negativo y también cuando x es
muy pero muy pero muy positiva vamos a
ver qué es lo que pasa con un polinomio
pero ahora de grado 3 vamos a hablar con
la función de grado 3 que es igual a a x
kubica + b x cuadrada + c x + de ok aquí
tengo un polinomio de grado cúbico y
vamos a tratar de hacer un análisis muy
parecido a éste para que tú me vayas
entendiendo mejor a qué me refiero
fíjate bien si este polinomio este
polinomio cumple que a es más grande que
0 ok
bueno si es más grande que 0 cuando
nosotros nos tomamos un valor muy pero
muy pero muy negativo en x esta
expresión esta expresión de aquí va a
ser negativa y entonces toda esta
expresión de aquí va a ser negativa es
decir que se va a ver algo más o menos
así va a ir siendo cada vez menos
negativo menos negativo menos negativo
menos negativo después va a ser una cosa
medio graciosa como por aquí va a ser
como una estilo montaña y después este
valor se va a volver cada vez más
más positivo más positivo más positivo
cuando x es un número positivo muy
grande entonces esta expresión de aquí
es positiva y todo esto se va a
convertir en algo positivo es decir que
así se vería la gráfica de una función
kubica cuando es mayor que es 0 ok y qué
pasa si a es menor que cero vamos a
ponerlo por aquí qué pasa cuando a es
menor que cero
bueno pues pasa justo lo contrario
cuando x es muy pero muy pero muy
negativo esta expresión de aquí va a ser
negativo y cuando lo multiplique por am
me va a dar un número positivo porque es
negativa y entonces obtendría algo muy
pero muy positivo y toda esta expresión
tanto temprano se volvería positiva así
que vamos a dibujar por aquí tengo algo
más o menos así va a ir bajando se va a
volver cada vez menos positiva y después
va a ir haciendo unas estilo montañas
muy parecidas a las que tengo aquí a la
izquierda y después se va a volver cada
vez más pero más negativo o espera deja
invitar esto que vamos a ver cada vez
más pero más negativo y se va a ver algo
más o menos así
una representación de una función
pública que se va a ver más o menos así
es decir que va a subir en un inicio y
después va a bajar ahora si me pregunto
por el comportamiento final ya sea de
una expresión cuadrática o cúbica es
decir de un polinomio realmente lo que
me estoy preguntando es qué es lo que
pasa en los extremos date cuenta como
habíamos dicho hace rato que aquí en los
extremos no importa qué es lo que pasa
que en medio bueno en una parábola
sabemos muy bien qué es lo que pasa pero
los extremos si es más grande que cero
entonces que se vuelve positiva se
vuelve un valor positivo y aquí bueno no
importa qué es lo que pasa en medio nos
vamos a fijar en los extremos el
comportamiento final y en dado caso de
que sea negativo entonces el
comportamiento final de esta parábola es
decir cuando estamos muy al inicio o muy
al final es que esto es negativo si a es
menor que cero ahora si tenemos un
polinomio cúbico entonces no nos va a
importar todas estas montañas chistosas
que tenemos por aquí estas montañas
graciosas las vamos a eliminar en un
principio yo lo que quiero ver es qué es
lo que va a pasar
al final o al inicio de este polinomio
público y si es más grande que 0 en una
edición esto se vuelve muy pero muy
negativo
es decir esta expresión se vuelve muy
negativa y después cuando acabamos
cuando tenemos un comportamiento final
es decir cuando x es muy pero muy pero
muy positiva tenemos un valor de ye
también muy positivo ahora fíjate que si
a es menor que cero no nos vamos a
importar nos vamos a fijar en esto que
está aquí en medio no nos vamos a
aplicar en esto que está aquí en medio y
solamente nos vamos a fijar en el
comportamiento final o inicial y en un
inicio esto se vuelve muy pero muy pero
muy positivo y después el valor de ye se
vuelve muy pero muy pero muy negativo en
el lado caso de que tengamos una función
pública ya sea menor que cero ahora
seguramente tú me vas a decir pero
porque estamos viendo esto sal y es que
esto nos va a ayudar bastante a poder
comprender una función y además a
poderlas identificar de una manera muy
rápida con el comportamiento final e
inicial vamos a ponerle aquí también el
comportamiento final
inicial
inicial de una función de un polinomio
nos podemos dar cuenta que es lo que
pasa y cuál es el polinomio al que nos
estamos refiriendo ahora lo padre de
esto es que ya analizamos el caso de
tener un polinomio cuadrática uno cúbico
pero se van a empezar a cumplir patrones
después de que necesitemos los
siguientes polinomios así que vamos a
fijarnos en un polinomio de grado cuarto
si yo tuviera bien
es igual a am x 4 más
x cúbica más c x cuadrada más de x más y
bueno en lugar de poner porque bueno
sabemos que es un número es un valor y
no me voy a meter ahorita en problemas
con él vamos a hablar de una manera
general así que en lugar de poner aquí
y nos confundamos con el valor de él voy
a poner
efe
aquí tengo un polinomio de grado cuarto
que es lo que va a pasar ahora con su
comportamiento final y con su
comportamiento inicial ahora para ver
cómo se comporta esta función en los
extremos es decir su comportamiento
final e inicial vamos a compararlo con
qué es lo que pasa en el comportamiento
de los extremos con esta función
cuadrática y te vas a dar cuenta que es
algo muy parecido fíjate bien si tenemos
aquí este polinomio de cuarto grado y
nos tomamos una equis que sea muy pero
muy pero muy negativa entonces este
valor de aquí va a ser algo muy positivo
porque cuando nosotros elevamos algo
negativo en la cuarta potencia
estamos convirtiéndolo en un valor muy
grande pero positivo y ahora si es mayor
que cero si a es más grande que cero
déjame bajar un poco a esta pantalla
para que lo veas mejor ok si a es mayor
que cero entonces esto de aquí será un
número positivo que al final le ganaría
todo esto y se vería más o menos así su
comportamiento inicial o su
comportamiento de los extremos empezaría
más o menos
ahora qué pasa si x es un valor muy pero
muy pero muy positivo bueno un número
muy positivo elevado a la cuarta
potencia si te das cuenta es un número
muy positivo y multiplicado por un
número positivo también me da algo
positivo es decir que al final todo esto
tendría una expresión muy positiva y
entonces se vería el comportamiento
final más o menos así y qué pasa en
medio bueno en medio más o menos debe de
pasar algo así
tenemos que tener algunas montañas un
poco graciosas como las que hemos
dibujado hace rato se vería más o menos
así tiene algunas montañas depende y eso
ya lo veremos con mucha calma en otros
vídeos antes de quitar esto y ponerlo
así ok pero lo que me importa analizar
en este vídeo es qué es lo que pasa con
el comportamiento final y con el
comportamiento inicial y bueno esto que
está aquí en medio este comportamiento
del medio no es lo más importante de
este vídeo así que bueno es más o menos
esto lo que ocurre en medio pero mi
comportamiento final ahora si lo
comparamos al comportamiento final e
inicial que teníamos aquí en esta cuadra
date cuenta que es muy parecido cuando
era positiva los dos salían hacia una
diapositiva los dos salen hacia una
diapositiva y ahora vamos a analizar qué
es lo que pasa cuando am es un menor que
cero cuando a es menor que cero
bueno pues date cuenta que esto sigue
siendo positivo si x es muy pero muy
pero muy negativa y algo positivo por
algo negativo me da algo negativo es
decir que se vería más o menos así va a
salir vamos a obtener un valor para esta
función negativo y ahora qué es lo que
va a pasar si x es muy pero muy pero muy
positiva si x es muy grande es muy
positiva este valor sigue siendo
positivo x la cuarta es positivo y algo
positivo por algo negativo me da algo
negativo por lo tanto toda esta
expresión me daría un valor negativo se
vería algo más o menos así y su
comportamiento en medio ya más o menos
te lo puedes imaginar es algo que sube
después debe de bajar después debe de
subir otra vez y después debe de bajar
es algo más o menos así aunque bueno
recuerda que no estamos en el vídeo del
comportamiento de enmedio así
y no nos interesa tanto lo que va a
pasar justo por aquí y esto más o menos
ya lo podemos ubicar pero estamos en el
vídeo del comportamiento en los extremos
y ahora si nos fijamos qué es lo que
pasó con esta función de cuarto grado a
comparación de qué es lo que pasó con
esta función cuadrática date cuenta que
cuando es positivo el comportamiento
final e inicial se va para arriba y de
igual manera aquí en nuestro polinomio
del cuarto grado se va para arriba el
comportamiento inicial y el final
también y cuando es negativa en esta
ecuación cuadrática el comportamiento
final e inicial se iba para abajo y aquí
también en este polinomio de cuarto
grado nuestro comportamiento al final e
inicial también se fue para abajo te das
cuenta de que es lo que está pasando si
tenemos una potencia par entonces
nuestro comportamiento final e inicial
siempre se va a ver muy parecido al
comportamiento final e inicial de una
parábola sea lo que sea que pase justo
aquí en medio el comportamiento final e
inicial de un polinomio que tenga grado
par es decir que su potencia más grande
aparte se va a ver a los dos para arriba
o los dos para abajo y más o menos ya te
puedes imaginar a qué vamos si yo aquí
pienso en el polinomio de grado 5 y
bueno nada más para hacerlo para que te
des cuenta de qué es lo que va a pasar
lo voy a poner aquí y es igual a equis a
la quinta más b x a la cuarta más todos
los demás ya sabes que sigue ahora me
voy a fijar en este polinomio de grado 5
y lo voy a comparar con este polinomio
de grado 3 y bueno si tenemos una
potencia par se ve más o menos así y ya
te puedes imaginar que cuando tenemos
una potencia y parte va a haber más o
menos así pero bueno para no dejarlo
vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa si
tenemos un polinomio de grado 5 si a es
positiva si a es positiva
entonces vamos a tener que cuando x es
muy pero muy pero muy negativa
este valor de aquí es negativo y
multiplicado por ahmed algo negativo y
entonces va a salir por acá va a salir
algo por acá y ahora si x es positiva x
quinta es un valor positivo y algo
positivo por algo positivo humedad
entonces a algo va a pasar pero esto va
a salir por acá y bueno de hecho lo que
pasa aquí en medio vamos a ver si no me
equivoco es que supo bajo su otra vez
vuelvo a bajar y después otra vez
subo pero quiero que analices el
comportamiento que está en los extremos
no me interesa tanto qué es lo que pasa
aquí yo lo que quiero analizar es lo que
pasa al final y al inicio y compararlo
con este polinomio de grado cúbico y si
te das cuenta pasa exactamente lo mismo
cuando nosotros tenemos que a es
positiva el comportamiento inicial se va
a un valor negativo y el comportamiento
al final se va a un valor positivo y
aquí pasa lo mismo y qué es lo que va a
pasar que te imaginas tú qué es lo que
va a pasar si nosotros tenemos a a menor
que cero a negativa bueno pues si a es
menor que cero entonces aquí vamos a
tener algún negativo por algo negativo
lo cual me va a dar algo positivo es
decir se va a ver más o menos así va a
empezar algo así después va a pasar algo
aquí en medium mapas de algo aquí en
medio pero lo que quiero que te des
cuenta
el comportamiento final cuando x es muy
pero muy pero muy positiva aquí me va a
dar algo positivo y algo positivo por
algo que es negativo me va a dar algo
negativo por lo tanto va a salir por acá
y bueno lo que pasa quien me dio eso no
es lo que nos interesa en este vídeo lo
que nos interesa en este vídeo es que te
des cuenta que el comportamiento en los
extremos de una función de grado impar
se va a ver muy parecido se va a ver
igual el comportamiento en los extremos
de esta función pública para cualquier
polinomio de grado un par que tú te
tomes de grado 5 de grado 3 de grado 7
el que tú quieras su comportamiento en
los extremos se va a ver exactamente
igual si es positiva se va a ver así ok
si es negativa se va a ver así y aquí lo
podemos ver y ahora si el polinomio es
de grado par x la cuarta x la sexta x
cuadrada su comportamiento de los
extremos va a ser exactamente el mismo
que la parábola es decir que si a es
positiva el comportamiento inicial y el
comportamiento final se va a ir para
arriba
aquí también pasa lo mismo y si es
negativa entonces el comportamiento
inicial el comportamiento final se va a
ver más o menos así hacia abajo y ya
está es justo esto lo que quería
contarte en este vídeo no nos importa
tanto qué tan loco se ponga aquí en
medio recuerda que lo importante va a
ser el comportamiento final e inicial el
comportamiento en los extremos y en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a ver un ejemplo
para que entiendas más para que nos
puede servir